[Music]
what
well hello everybody thank you for
joining our program I'd like to know uh
this is one of our favorite programs
here at Secrets unsealed because we get
to hear from you what your questions are
concerning the Bible and um we really
Delight in the moment when we receive
the questions now I must warn you that
we receive so many questions that they
might not be answered in the immediate
future because it takes sometimes weeks
to get all caught up because we have a
big pile of questions but I would
encourage you to continue tuning in and
sending in your questions and we
eventually will get to those questions
and uh so please continue tuning in let
me give you the uh email address where
you can send us the questions you'll see
it on the screen TVM tv.org once again
TVM
tv.org
also we want to encourage you to
continue praying for this Ministry not
only for I'd like to know but for all of
the programs that we produce here and I
want to express my appreciation for
supporting these programs financially
because uh there is a cost to producing
them uh we don't make big appeals for uh
funding from the people who view our
programs but if the Lord touches your
heart we would be glad to receive
financial support uh from you for this
program and for other programs of our
ministry I have with me uh Pastor David
Salasar uh he is a real asset to our
ministry he's greatly lightened my road
on my on my load because uh I used to
have to do the Spanish all by myself
because almost everybody here is either
not uh willing to speak uh in Spanish or
English and um so I don't have to
coordinate the Spanish work anymore uh
Pastor salad does a phenomenal job and
we're very glad glad to have him with us
uh thank you Pastor for participating in
this program and for everything you do
for the ministry thank you Pastor is
always an honor and a privilege for me
to share this time and be able to spend
time with you discussing the word of God
and teaching or actually learning from
you is is always a pleasure and a
blessing and uh I'm very happy to also
be part of ministry and U we're here to
serve what can I say and one of the
wonderful things folks is that U with a
Salasar family we get four for the price
of one how about that because his wife
does children's stories she did the
children's programming at our Summit
that just ended a couple of days ago and
the daughters they tell children stories
I mean this is a phenomenal family and
we're so glad to have them with us would
you please pray absolutely Pastor yes
let us
pray our gracious Heavenly Father we are
thankful to you today for allowing us to
participate of your work and to be able
to uh be used by you to um explain and
to share from your word the answers that
uh some of the questions that our
friends have sent uh we know that you
are the source of all wisdom of all uh
righteousness of all instruction and so
we ask you right now to send your Holy
Spirit to our midst to our minds that we
may speak according to your will and
that all answers May bring someone
closer to you and bring them to a full
realization that your word is truth we
pray all this in Jesus name amen amen
well uh last time uh somebody sent us uh
two questions and we were able to answer
one in the time constraints that we had
in our last program but so now we want
to answer the second question uh and uh
this is the question we were having a
Bible class on the sanctuary but the
majority of the students said that there
is no physical sanctuary in heaven is
this
correct uh then uh a comment we read
Exodus
25:40 when the Lord told Moses to build
the sanctuary according to the pattern
shown him but one of the teachers said
this does not mean there is a physical
sanctuary in heaven I am willing to
learn the truth but sometimes I have
studies with this group and I am
confused so the basic question is is
there a literal physical sanctuary in
heaven or not okay um
well the answer in Hebrews 8 chapter um
8:
1 and
two I would like just to read those two
verses very simple it says there now of
the things which we have spoken this is
the PS we have such a high priest who is
set on the right hand of the Throne of
the Majesty in the heavens a minister of
the sanctuary and of the true t knle
which the Lord pitched and not men
now I don't know Pastor Bo but um that
word pitched means to actually build to
construct to put it together and you
should know because you're a contractor
exactly and it's a Greek word that means
you know actually building something
physically is not something you just say
uh let me just create as a as a as a art
form it's actually building something
something and here in these two verses
we see clearly from the word of God that
the sum of what Paul's been speaking
through all the chapters below or before
that is Christ Jesus Christ he is the
true high priest and he ministering in
the sanctuary which was built not by man
so it's not the Moses Tabernacle is
nothing to do not the temples that were
built in in not the world but the one
that God himself pitched the one that he
actually built which is in heaven
I know that some people are teaching
contrary to this but in the Bible and
spirit prophecy there is no indication
actually there is only indication that
there is a physical real Tabernacle in
heaven and so this is where I think we
need to uh you know be be clear and be
willing to you know stick with the Bible
and what it says and not what someone
who has maybe uh you know information or
or or even title in his name is saying
the word of God is clear to me and I
rather stick to the word of God you know
it's interesting that the book of
Hebrews refers to the Earthly sanctuary
as a shadow of the Heavenly Sanctuary
you can't have a shadow without a
reality that's projecting the shadow
exactly you know I ride my bicycle five
miles every morning and depending on the
hour when I go there's this great big uh
light pole on a corner and if I go out
early the shadow that's being projected
by that light pole covers almost the
entire uh
street but then if I go out a little bit
later there is no Shadow because the
shadow has reached the substance
exactly and and so that's the the
connection between the Old and New
Testament the Old Testament is a shadow
and the purpose of the Shadow was to
point to the reality and when the
reality reaches when the when the shadow
reaches the reality then there's no more
Shadow exactly because the the reality
is there and uh and yet you cannot have
a shadow unless you have a reality that
projects the shadow so if the Earthly
Sanctuary is the shadow of the Heavenly
then there must be a real Heavenly
Sanctuary that's right that's right now
what why would people Pastor today um
you know question that because I I feel
sad that um our friend has Bible study
with this group that you know many of
them and the one that teaches is telling
them that you know there's no C in
heaven I'm assuming they are Adventists
perhaps because we're the only ones that
have that that knowledge but why do you
think they are they're teaching that
noway I mean what's the
purpose I think that the purpose is that
they they believe that uh they don't
believe that things in heaven can really
be
concrete uh you know they've been
influenced by Greek philosophy let me
put it that way you know as administ we
believe that uh there's no such thing as
a soul without a body of course the body
and the spirit are the soul right or the
person uh but then when it comes to
things like this oh you know is there
really a material sanctuary in heaven
you know that doesn't make any sense
everything up there is
spiritual and they and they think that
spiritual means
non-tangible we usually think of the
angel that way we say the angels are
kind of like ghostly you know immaterial
beings but but obviously they they're
composed of matter because Lucifer is
going to be burnt it reduced to ashes
you can't have ashes unless you have
matter yeah so elen white says that the
fear of making uh our future life too
concrete has led many to deny uh the the
realities that exist in heaven I believe
that there's a real tree of life yes
there is a real River of Life mhm there
is a there there is u a real throne of
God there you can't say that the water
flows from the Throne of God Throne
there's no throne but there's water yeah
you know it doesn't make any
sense Heaven is a real
place real material place the trouble is
we think that matter is bad because
matter deteriorates here in this world
yeah but you know God created matter at
the beginning and it was very very good
so we need to be very careful not to
become spiritualist when it comes to the
sanctuary amen and and also wouldn't
also I think in a sense without
realizing people that deny the existence
of a sent in heaven are also attacking
the work of Christ as a high priest I
mean in in in essence because what is he
then just is if if the s in heaven is
not real then his experience of being a
high priest is only in name but it's not
a reality not real experience but you
know is it truly that the case of course
not Christ is our high priest and he's
interceding there's a process of of of
what he's doing right now his work right
now is intercession for us to make us
you know be one with him to cleanse us
from all unrighteousness to work in our
hearts to give up sin so the work of s
this
intercession is so important for the
Plan of Redemption that I believe that
the enemy is using the attack those that
attack the Sanctuary message the fact
that there's not Sanctuary to you know
undermine this beautiful message
undermine the role of Christ even now
and if we reject the sanctuary message
that there's a real sanctuary in heaven
then Christ is not really necessarily
interceding for us either you know and
and everything becomes becomes to you
know lose its purpose or or or or
concepts yeah those who deny that
there's a real sanctuary in heaven they
say well do you really believe that
Jesus Takes blood and he sprinkles Blood
on the you know on the Ark in the most
holy place the fact is that Jesus does
plead his blood it's running in his
veins it's real blood absolutely right
but but uh you know there's no
sacrificial system in heaven because the
sacrifice took place on Earth the court
is the Earth yeah and the the sacrifices
took place on earth now Jesus pleads his
blood in the Holy place and then in the
most holy place of the sanctuary and
it's real blood absolutely because it's
flowing through his veins mhm now we
need to understand however that the
Earthly
Sanctuary is only a scale God showed
Moses only a scale model of the Heavenly
Sanctuary the Heavenly Sanctuary is much
bigger larger glorious than the Earthly
sanctuary in other words God didn't show
Moses the Heavenly Sanctuary he showed
him a scale model of the Heavenly
Sanctuary something that he could
actually do here yeah like you do in in
construction you know you have you have
a little mock model of the F finish
project you know it's to scale yeah but
it's still not the reality it points to
something far greater and that's why uh
in Exodus chter 40 which is mentioned in
uh in the question Exodus 25 and verse
40 uh God says to Moses uh if we can
find this
verse uh Exodus 25 and verse 40 says see
to it that you make them according to
the pattern which was shown you on the
mountain it was the pattern that was
shown to Moses but the sanctuary is far
greater than uh even what God showed
Moses or the Earthly Sanctuary but it's
the scale absolutely and I believe also
uh this is why the Tabernacle that Moses
did was different in a sense to the
temple itself that David built or I'm
sorry that Solomon
and both were shown by the Lord you know
and they both had uh as you mentioned
you know they they were like a a scale
of of of what the Heavenly Sanctuary is
but it's not exactly exact copy of what
the Heavenly Sanctuary looks like
because it's really not possible to do
the same thing on Earth but the Lord
wanted the basic principles of what it
will teach you know to an applicable to
the you know to the nation of Israel so
they understood in a in a in a practice
iCal way in a illustration you know how
it was how the Lord will deal with the
issue with sin and and and this is why
the difference between the the
Tabernacle and the temple both were
inspired by the Lord to do right you
know but a little different right and
and the
sanctuary um the purpose of the
sanctuary in heaven it's a literal
Sanctuary is functional right is to show
the different phases of the work of
Christ so you know we can't get caught
up either in the G geography alone yes
because the purpose of the geography is
to point to different functions of uh
Christ in the Heavenly Sanctuary so it's
not either or it's
both um you know Revelation four and
five speaks about the
sensor it speaks about the candal laabam
seven Branch
Candlestick 11: 19 speaks about seeing
the Ark of the C an mhm and inside the
Ark of the Covenant are the original
tables of the law yes are we to
understand that that there's no Arc of
Covenant in heaven and that there's no
tables of the law inside the ark we
would have to contradict what Ellen
White says she very clearly said that
she saw the Ark in heaven and she saw
the tables of stone in the ark
containing the ten commandments so um
you know to say that there's no real
literal sanctuary in heaven is to
uh question the inspiration of the
writings of the spirit of Prophecy and
and you know this you know also
revelation we see time and time again
the fact of the Tabernacle being shown
or the temple being shown or the fact
that uh the ark you know was opened or
closed and so we realize that this
language of Tabernacle of the sanctuary
in heaven is given you know uh a lot of
time and is mentioned several times
throughout Revelation which by then
there was of course no longer any Temple
you know no longer any standing temple
in on Earth therefore we're speaking
specifically of the of the one in heaven
um so I I believe that this is maybe
something that we need to encourage our
friends to to study to to realize that
we need to be sighting with the word of
God Amen and not with what men says you
know and you know I want to read a
statement Ellen White predicted that
there was going to be study groups like
this that that said that there is no
Sanctuary uh in uh the book uh councils
to writers and editors page 53 the
original sources is review and Herald
May 25 1905 by the way this is late in
the life of Ellen White because she died
in 1915 she's writing this in 1905 wow
and she wrote this in the future
deception of every kind is to arise and
we want solid ground for our feet we
want solid pillars for the building mhm
not one pin is to be removed from that
which the Lord has established the enemy
will bring in false theories such as the
doctrine that there is no
Sanctuary this is one of the points on
which there will be a departing from the
faith wow where shall we find safety
unless it be in the truth that the Lord
has been giving for the last 50 years so
she predicted that there would going to
be those who were going to say that
there is no sanctuary and she said this
is one point where there's going to be a
departing from the faith so this is an
important issue absolutely and a very
good question from the person who sent
it amen amen I hope that our friend cert
can be uh you know guided in the right
direction and he can continue to follow
the word of God and be worried you know
or concerned about some of these
teachings that are being going around
and he's not the only person you know
that sends it questions like this uh
there are many like you said groups that
are you know questioning the doctrines
that the Lord has revealed to us to be
truth amen well the next question you
know sometimes we get questions for
which there is no biblical answer yes
because they deal with uh God's plans
for the future so I'm going to go
through this and then maybe we can offer
an opinion MH but I'm not sure we can
offer a thus sayith the Lord that's true
uh this is what it says this is sent by
Anonymous in other words somebody who
did not give their name or
location I was married to my husband Sam
for 20 wonderful years he not only
raised his voice to me he not he not
once raised his voice to me and he never
left our home Angry he was a fellow
believer I would find him reading his
Bible in the mornings before leaving
work my husband died November 2021 due
to covid-19 how how sad that's sad
that's so sad I know that my dear
husband is resting in the Lord and I
have read in the spirit of Prophecy that
we will not be married in heaven this
makes me so very sad and am having a
difficult time with the grieving
process it's really wonderful when
somebody longs to be married to the
husband in the world to come she
continues do you know if Sam will
remember that we were married once we
get to heaven will we still hold the
memories we had together will Adam and
Eve not be married anymore once they get
to heaven I don't understand how God's
children that have remarried again
explain to their newborn to their new
spouses in heaven uh so uh the qu
several questions here uh
number one do you know if Sam will
remember that we were married will we
still hold the memories that we had
together um so those are the two basic
questions so what can we say about that
well you know Pastor I know that there
are many of those who have been
remarried and uh if they have a good
relationship or a great relationship the
question is you know or you know uh why
can I I not keep that experience in
heaven uh if I been married just once in
my life it seems that a lot of times we
think uh it's going to be okay you know
the Lord might keep that marriage in
heaven intact I mean in the case of Adam
and Eve I've heard people say no you
know God can keep families together and
and there's no reason why he wouldn't uh
we're really kind of speculating here
maybe just sharing some ideas as you
mentioned but uh the Bible speaks
something that I think is very important
even when he speaks remember that the
there was this question that the S
Sadducees came to the Lord and asked
about somebody that had married uh and
they lost the wife lost the husband and
she had to marry to the second brother
and all through seven and they all died
and you know I know that was a trick
question trying to make Christ you know
explain something that they knew would
be hard to explain but Christ the way
that he answered and I think that we
need to just emphasize this it said says
uh verse 29 of Matthew 22 he tells them
ye do Heir not knowing the scriptures
nor the power of God and I think that
some things we do not really know and
God has not really revealed to us but we
do understand that there's a lot more
that he does know a lot more power that
he has and uh I will say that if there
are good memories if there's good
experiences if you had that type of
relationship where you love one another
in in pure affection those memories and
those experiences I don't see why the
Lord will have not to take away from
your mind I believe that that experience
can be kept you know the good things we
will remember only the good things that
happen on on earth now exactly how the
Lord will deal as far as families
marriage couples those that were married
once or you know remarried and both
husbands or both spouses are there well
you know those things I live it to the
Lord to really deal with all I know is
that he calls us to you know that we
have to be careful not to ER for not
knowing the scriptures or the power of
God we have to just trust God will fix
it in a way that we will be absolutely
happy and you know that relationship
that friendship maybe it would we would
have such a good friendship that it
would be you know even closer than we
can think on Earth you know and
therefore I feel that our friend needs
to not feel worried I think that if
she's faithful and and Sam was faithful
they will be together in heaven uh
whether or not as a couple or as a
married that is not for me to decide but
I believe that the Lord will make it
perfect that's what I can know you know
the problem is many times we evaluate
the
future in the light of the present MH uh
obviously she has wonderful memories
yeah of the marriage with her husband uh
but what is going to what is going to be
there is So Glorious it's much better
compared compared to what we have here
that we really cannot evaluate heav oh
you know I want to be with my husband
and you know I want to remember all the
good times that we had we're thinking in
the light of what uh what occurs here
but what God has there is so much more
glorious than what we have here amen
that that it's no comparison for example
Ellen White uh had a vision and for me
this is an amazing Vision she was
transported to the Future
when she after the resurrection meets
some of the some of the um millerites
yeah among which is brother
Stockman and brother Stockman and uh and
some of the others Stockman died just a
short while before 1844 right and uh she
said we uh they asked what had
transpired after they had died what
happened in 1844 did the Lord come in
1844 and uh Ellen White says that they
could not bring to mind any of the any
of the things because the scene There
Was So
Glorious that it just totally eclipsed
The Experience here so you know we need
to be concerned mostly about getting
there yes and when we get there it's
going to be so glorious that we're
probably not even going to remember a
lot of the things that transpired in
this life absolutely of course there's a
lot of things that we don't want want to
remember right is going to is God going
to erase those things from our mind are
they going to be there to torment us
throughout eternity you know no
everything there is going to be
beautiful everything's going to be nice
uh you know everything is going to PE be
peace and joy and love and it's going to
be so
glorious that there's no comparison with
what happened on this Earth so so my uh
words to to this uh dear lady uh whose
name name we don't have is that what God
has prepared for you is So Glorious so
magnificent M that you're not even going
to be thinking about well are we going
to remember the good times we had on
Earth the times there are going to be so
much greater than the ones on Earth that
the ones on Earth are not even going to
come to mind that is how true Pastor you
know as as I heard once uh preacher say
you know if you have imagine Heaven well
is not that you cannot even imagine you
know how heaven looks like whatever you
have thought of heaven looks like
whatever you think heaven will be uh
it's not because as the Bible speaks of
you know things that God has prepared
have not even come into our mind have
not even come to our imagination it's so
beyond our comprehension that the
experience of joy of of rejoicing of
loving of of what God has in store
really will Eclipse anything here even
the good things in on Earth are going to
pale I mean are complet completed to
pale compared to what we receive in
heaven so the Lord wants us to have that
experience that assurance that he will
make things perfect beyond our
comprehension and this is why we can ER
not knowing the power of God and the
power that he has to make things even
much better than we can ever expect and
the Book of Revelation says the former
things will not come to mind amen so
maybe that would be the closest uh
answer to the question the former things
will not come to mind yeah and the
reason why is because it's so glorious
he's beyond our so much
Bliss that the things that occurred on
this Earth even our marriages here on
Earth are not going to be a big
thing uh being in the presence of the
Lord well um time has flown by and um
we're just about finished with our
program remember remember to send us
your questions to TVM tv.org
hope to see you next time God
[Music]
bless